誰でも喜んで期待する
しかし 達しがたい 4つの目的があります
これ 財界であるならば
夢が 4つあるんですよ
夢はあるのはあるんだけど
なかなか達しがたい パーリ語で言えば
チャッターロダンマ イッター
カンター マナーパ ドゥルラバー
ローカスニー これ訳はできないんですよ
チャッターローダンマというのは 4つの目的項目ということで
イッターっていうのは欲しいんですね
あればなんとありがたいという気持ちにイッターっていう意味なんです
カンターっていうのはとてもいいものなんですね
ああ 欲しいなという気持ちと
カンターとてもいいもので
マナーパっていうのはもうあったら大変心が喜ぶ
誰でももう あ それならもういいに決まってるんだというふうに
喜びを与える ドゥルラバーっていうのはけふありえない
難しい そんなあるわけじゃない
ローカスにこの世のこの世の中では
だからこの世の中でとってもあってほしい
ありがたい 幸福な 楽しいものが 4つあるんですが
なかなかなかなかそれは夢だけではちゃいますよと
だから現代風に言えば
誰でも夢見る 4つの項目なんです
1はこの所有の楽 それはもうまあ
財産があることなんですね
何の困ることもなく 財産があった方が悪くないでしょうと
だからどんな財界の人でも財産いっぱいあった方がよろしいと思っているんです
だからいろいろ希望はあるんです
家を買いたいとかね 車を買いたいとか
で 奥さんにもうちょっとしたダイヤでもルビーでもついてるネックレス一つでも買ってあげたいとか
指輪でも買ってあげたいとか
奥様方もね まあフランス製のイタリア製の
あの 何といいますか 服なんか買いたいとかね
イタリアの靴しか靴ばっかり履くことできればなんてありがたいなあとかね
って思ったりするでしょうに
それにはお金が必要なんですよ
何をやろうと思っても
で 現代的に言えばお金なんですよ
昔は財産ということでね
とにかく財界であるならば
すごく財産的に豊かでいたいという夢があるんです
でも 世の中では この自分が十分満足できるぐらい財産がある人っていうのはほとんどまれなんですね
誰に聞いたってもうちょっとあった方がいいという状態でいるんです
なんとかなんとか間に合わせているだけで
間に合ってるわけでもないんです
ちょっとでも計算がおかしくなっちゃうと
もう大変なことになるんです
で パーリ語でボーダー名ウッパイジャンとサハダンメーナ
しかし 頭のいい人はこういうふうに思うんですね
正当な方法で得た財産がありますようにと
お金が欲しいんだからって言って
みんなじゃあ銀行強盗でもしようかとか思わないでしょう
そう思わないです で まあ昨日もこの写メ見せたんですけど
この人々いっぱい集まっているところで
どこかからこのあの 警備の車が来てお金を持っていくんですね
私は子供にも見てください
これもいっぱいお金 この車に乗って今持っていくんだよと
その時でもやっぱり強盗するんだったら一番もう道路ですからね
そんなに難しくないと思いますけど
もう隠れて知らないようにごまかし
ステゴプラスで持ってくるのはできないんですよ
日本では でも誰もそんなことはやろうと思わないんですね
ですから 誰でも金持ちにはなりたいんだけど
正当な方法で 合法的に金持ちになりたいんです
罪を犯したり また乱暴な方法で得る財産では人生は楽しめないんです
隠れていなくちゃダメだからね
十分財産があり またそれは正当な方法で得たものであるならば
その財産は無駄になくならない
他人にとられない 強盗してもう 1,000万ぐらい持って隠しておいたっても
もう買い物もできないし
何もできないし 見つけたら全部持っていくでしょうね
しかし 正当な方法で得た金だったら
誰もそれに手を出すことはできないんです
それから無駄にならないんです
ちゃんと計算して堂々と使えるんです
大体無駄遣いする気持ちになると
このお金が正当に得たものじゃないんです
はい それが 1番目ですね
何か異論ありますか？最後の方々は金持ちにはなりたくないやと思う方でもいますかね
もう金ってのはとんでもないもう後ろものでね
私には要りませんとか
大体そういうことはないんです
だから この夢の 1 それで正当な財産について
ちょっと経典の後半に出てくるものは最後にあの
ちょっと挙げたんです
で 私は順番変えてから考えたのは
やっぱりお釈迦様の順番が正しいでしょうと
一旦変えちゃったんだから
まあしょうがないんです
お釈迦様はこの正当な方法を最後に教えてあげましたけど
ウッターナ ビリヤーディ ガテーヒ ボーヘーヒ
生けす精進 努力して得た財産ということ
バーハーバラ パリチテーヒ
腕を振ってという意味ですね
自分自身の能力 技術を駆使して財を得ること
それが正当な方法なんです
自分の持っている能力
自分の知識 あれこれを駆使して使って
あるいは技術とか学んだならば
そういうものをいっぱい使って金儲かる
もう詐欺じゃないんです
それが仏教が言う正当な収入
セーダ ワッキッテーヒ
汗を流して仕事をすること
ダンミケーヒ ダンマラッデーヒ
罪を犯さず 正当な方法で得た財産ということ
だから仕事のために罪を犯してはならないんですね
あるいはほんのちょっと仕事をして
もう強引にものすごくうるさく話を喋って喋って
たくさん金を取ると それも正当じゃないんです
ですから ちゃんとした自分の仕事に適した分の収入を得るということなんです
はい はい 次に行きます
2番目の夢は認められること
これ名誉ですね 認められる楽
これ 2番目なんです 真っ先に金が欲しいんです
金があって豊かになったら
社会から認めてほしいんですよ
あんた誰です？あっち行きなさいとかね
いう状態だったら あまり人生は面白くないんです
まあ大体 知っていて 何々さんとかね
誰でもよく知ってる人で
有名人で 社会から認められる人で
いろんな集まりに呼ばれるとかね
そういう人になりたいんですね
2番目に 金だけあって
誰も自分の名前さえ知らないところ
どこかで隠れていてもね
人生楽しいとは思えないんです
金がある人にとってはね
誰も出会いできない山のど真ん中
どこかに家を作ってね
一人ぼっちでいることは不可能じゃないんだけど
楽しいとは思えないんです
だったらドーンともの一番高価なところで家を作っていればもう楽しいんです
それでまたいろんな人々は知っていて
もう例えば日本だったら日本全国民は知ってる人とかね
なってくると なおさら楽しいんですね
だからやっぱり名誉があるっていうことは
順番的には 2番目になるんです
ボーケラッダサハダンメーナヤソーマンアブガッチャク
サハニャーティーサハウパッジャエーイ
これで一般的よりはちょっと違うところがあるんです
正当な方法で財産を得てから
私と私の家族 親族 師匠に名誉がありますようにと読み上げるんです
なんで自分以外な人のことを考えているんですか？これがポイントなんです
社会に求められること
人気があること 尊敬されることも
サイケが期待するものです
家族 親族 指導者たち 誰にでも不名誉なことがあったら困るんです
自分に人気あっても 自分の息子が何かとんでもないことをしたならば
もう大変ですよ 親戚の中でも変なことをする人がいると
自分の名誉はものすごく引き継ぐんですよ
だから名誉の場合は 自分と家族と親族
それから指導者たち 教えてくれる人々
みんなしっかりしていないとダメなんですね
困るんです だから それに我々の勉強するポイントあるんですよ
非難されないということは
自分だけでは十分じゃないんです
社会に非難されない お兄ちゃんはどこでも褒め称えられますけど
弟の方がもう犯罪扱いだったなると
お兄ちゃんの立場もないんですよ
だから この非難されないこと
認められることっていうのは
家族みんなに必要なことなんです
それだけじゃなくて その人の教えたり
アドバイスしたり 指導したりする人々も
社会で認められる人々でなければいけません
なんで頭の悪い人々はあえてもう東大に入ろうとしてるんですかね
なんでしょうかね 向こうはすごい認められてる組織なんです
だから東大という名前で社会で生きてみようではないかということなんですよ
徹底的に勉強したいんだからっていう気持ちでは入れないんです
むちゃくちゃ勉強しますけど
あんまり頭が鋭いかどうか
また別の話なんです で
頭がいい人っていうのは
すぐすぐ その瞬間 その瞬間で見事に仕事をしていて
どんな問題が起きても
それを解決して乗り越えていくんです
そんなのは学校で教えてくれないんです
だってどんな問題が起こるかわからないでしょうに
生きている上では だから学校の教えは必要ですけど
それはどのように使うのかと
そのインスピレーションですよ
頭がいいということは
だから 大学出たことがなくても
社会で一番トップのところで仕事できる人っていうのはいくらでもいます
それだけ有名なアメリカの大学とかね
日本の東大とか ああいうどこかどこか入っちゃうと
その肩書きで自分の立場を作るんですね
その場合も学校が名誉があるんですね
認められるので それで自分も助かるんです
もし怪しい学校だったら
自分がいくら頭が良くても
大変危険なんですよ 今インターネットでもスパムが来るんですよ
あなたには博士号を取れるようになりましたとかね
MBAを取れるようになりましたとかね
そこにお金出したところで
何か紙一枚印刷してくるかもしれませんけど
こんなのは肩書きとして会社に出したり
転居で立候補するとき出したりすると
もうどうなるかわからないんですよ
だから師匠 師匠たちの名誉も自分の名誉のために必要なんです
自分が学んだ学校は何の問題もなく
社会で大変優れている
認められている学校だったら
自分が安心して生きていられます
だから 在家の人々の 2番目の夢っていうのは
名誉っていう一言葉なんです
認められるっていうことなんです
認められるならばとっても楽しいんですよ
自分が認められているんだっていうと
その場合は世間と違って
お釈迦様がすべて語っているんです
認められるっていうことは
あなただけじゃないんだよと
誰かにやっちゃうと あなたの場合は
あのタレントさんとかいたでしょ
ちょっと前の古い話ですけど
息子が麻薬取ったりして
もうタレントの仕事を辞める羽目になったりとかね
あれは息子がやったことだから
私は関係ないと言えないでしょうに
自分の仕事まで危うく状態になっちゃうんですよ
だからそういうことだから
それ見てください いかにお釈迦様が物事をすごく完全に見ているのかっていうこと
名誉の場合はみんなの名誉を考えているんです
はい 次  ３番目の楽 健康で長生きできる
楽 日本ではね お金もないのにそればっかり先に思っちゃうんで
順番がちょっとね
ボーゲラッダサハダンメーナヤサンラッダサハニャーテーヒサハウパッジャエーヒチラインジーワーミディーガマッダーユンパーリーニティというところ
正当に財産を得て 私と家族
親族 師匠たちが社会の敬意を得たところで
私が長寿でありますように
3番目の夢 長生きしたいんだよと
早死になりたくないんだと
だっていっぱい財産があるし
社会に認めているし  1週間で死んじゃうとなんか悔しいでしょうね
それだったら日本の勲章と何の変わりもないんですね
もうそろそろ死ぬまで待ってるでしょうに
あれほど社会に貢献してね
一生かけて  あの人はあと 1ヶ月
2ヶ月すらもたないだろうというと
勲章を決めるんですね
ものすごい嫉妬深いんですよ
それよくないですよ 人の能力
すぐ褒めるべきなんです
人から良いことしたら
すぐそれを褒め称えてあげなくちゃいけないんです
そうなってくると 後輩の人々も頑張るし
まあその人はこれからも気をつけなくちゃいけないと
なおさら頑張らなくちゃいけないということもあるんです
で 死ぬまで死ぬ 3ヶ月前までますのは
まあこれは褒めたことにならないんですよ
かえって気持ち悪い 時々私はテレビでしかそういうニュース見られませんが
見ているといろんな人の考えて
なんであんたそこまで行くのかと
なんでそれ断らないのかと
今まで全然もう気にもしてなかった人がもう車椅子になって
で 尿を出すためにあの便も
車椅子にさせたまんまです
そこであちらに行くっていうのはね
断った方がもっとかっこいいと思いますけど
別に天皇陛下に失礼なわけじゃなくて
何か決めることじゃないんだから
まあそれは余談の話で
どうでもいいんですけど
やっぱり名誉があってからはもう長生きしたいという
どんな人間のも希望なんですね
長生きするということは健康であると同じ意味なんです
病気で長生きということは成り立ちませんからね
病気で短命になっちゃいますからね
大富豪であっても 人は病弱なら人生は楽しくありません
すごい病弱だったらもうそれほどものすごい苦しいんです
財産があるのに使えない
食べ物があるのに食べられないとかね
で 自家用ジェット機持ってますけど
乗れないとか 体の体調が悪くて何にもないんですね
だからまあ例えばもうジェット機の場合はね
パイロットを雇うことは
人も持っている人にとっては何のこともないんだけど
誰でも自分が元気で もう自分でもそこを操縦してどこかへ飛んでいくとかね
だったら気分がいいと思いますよ
そういうわけで 財産があってからはやっぱり健康でいることも必要な夢なんです
はい  4番目 死後天界に生まれる楽
ちょっと欲深いんですね
ハハハ カヤスヴェーガ パランマラナ スグティン サッガン ローカン ウパッチャ ミーティ
で お金持ちでもうすごい人気者でいて
その上長生きして これから死んだら天国に行きたいんです
これ別に冗談じゃない
誰が死んでから地獄に落ちたいんですかね
この世で金持ちになればいい
地獄あと後から地獄に落ちたってもっていうのは言う人はいるんだけど
それは金持ちになれないんだから言ってるんです
もう諦めてるんだ 金持ちになるならば
死後地獄に落ちたっても構いませんよというのは
金持ちになれないということははっきりしている
人間誰でももう罪を犯す人でも罪を犯しちゃったんだけど
地獄には行きたくないんですね
だから死んだら天国に行きたいという気持ちもあります
死後天国に生まれるという保証さえあれば
老後の人生さえも楽しいんです
よく考えてください 誰にでも老後っていうことはあるんです
老後と言うんです 老はないんですけどね
なんで老中と言わないんですかね
で 年取るんですね その時はかなり精神的には苦しいんです
財産は子供たち持ってるわ
お金の管理は自分にはさせないわ
で みんな言われる通り
言われたものを食べて
言われたことをやって生活しなくちゃいけないわ
今まで大きな人間でいたのに
すごく精神的に苦しいんですよ
このリーダーでいた人がリーダーから落とされて
みんなに言われる通りにやる操り人形になっちゃうんですよ
これってすごい精神的なショックなんです
しかし 本人にはもし保証があったら
死後天国だと決まってるんだから
それだったらまあ車椅子でいるのはどうってことないんです
すごいニコニコとみんなの世話を受けて生活できるようになるんです
だから これは 4番目の夢ということになるんです
以上 サイケが夢見る希望願望なのです
では  5番目ありますか？お釈迦様は 4つしか教えてないんです
できれば挑戦してみてください
皆様サイケですからね
ちょっと真剣に挑戦してみてください 5
番目言えるのかと 減ることはできます
それはその本人の能力範囲で考える
私に金さえあればいいんだとかね
バカですよ 金だけあったっても
社会から散々非難されるならば
警察が追っているならば
何の楽しみもないんですよ
だから四はまあ引くことできるんだけど
それも間違いなんです
私は聞いているのが 5番目の何かあるのかと
世の中の人間考える夢
ありますか？何か思い出すこと
これ 2500年古い話ですよ
現代人はもっと新しい夢とか
いくら考えても出てこないと思いますよ
何かやっと考えて言ったっても
この 4つの中に入るんです
これがお釈迦様が絶対的な解脱者である
完全に悟ったという証拠なんです
そういうことで我々には覚えやすい
これから覚えておきましょう
在家ならどんな希望 願望
夢を持っているのかと社会に言われたら
皆様は途方に暮れるんですよ
答えられなくて  環境のいいところで住みたいとか
あんまりいい答えじゃないんですよ
退職したらスイスかオーストラリアかどこかで
もう老後を生活したいとか
それが夢だよとか 本当に面白くないんです
そんなものは それというのは
ただ金があればの話でしょうにね
だから世間ではその質問を出されても
人の夢は何なのかと あ
これは数きれないほどあるものだとかね
それぞれの人は自分の夢を持ってるんだとか
すっごく大雑把で曖昧で中途半端なんです
だから仏教を学んでおいてください
この 4つ覚えていれば
そのところでもう誰よりも優れた教養を持っているはずなんです 4
つだよと覚えておけば
しかし 稀有である やられないんですよ
一興観と学ぶ その 4つの夢の形容詞ですね
幸福と言える 楽しい 大いに好むものですが
ドゥッラドローカスに
この 4つの希望は実現することはとても難しい
稀有なものであると 罪を犯さず
正当な方法で大富豪になることを考えれば理解できると思いますよ
皆さんもちょっと考えてください
何も悪いことをしないで
何も乱暴なことをしないで
何も強引なことをしないで
大富豪になるのと 誰でもそれだったら無理だと言うでしょう
今 世の中ですっごい金を持ってる人というのは
かなり乱暴なんですよ
かなり残酷なんです かなり悪いことしてるんです
たまたま見つかるでしょ
あのインサイ 何でしたっけ？取り引き
あのインサイダー 何でしたっけ？取り引き
そんなことだったら そういう簡単に金儲かります
でも正しく頑張っちゃえばもう知ってますね
どれぐらいでしょうかと
他の店も同じなんで難しい
みんな夢で終わっちゃうんですよ
誰かがすごく真面目で素直でしっかりと仕事をしていると
もう乱暴な連中がいろいろごまかして
正直で素直な人はそのままで
世の中はそんなもんなんですよ
だからお釈迦様はこれって稀有であると
稀であるというふうにおっしゃっているんです